[Music]
the song was written by a doctor if you
cut someone open they will keep bleeding
I've decided that if I'm hungover I'm
just gonna commit and you're right I
don't know the difference between the
words commit and overcompensate I think
this is my 2016 look like I finally
found it bottom of the ninth found my
look guess where this shirts from no
it's from Party City style icon I know
you're welcome oh okay huh don't live
your life like the rest of the pack oh
yeah it's hi my name is grace Helbig if
you don't know now you know your life is
different now my aesthetic is animal
from the Muppets meets vacation dad and
I'm cool with it welcome to this video
this is a dream of consciousness video
was that cool I know your girl is
hungover TG is Saturday night was SAT
you are night do you know that emoji
that was Saturday night father to
maestro of consciousness videos if you
don't know anything about them cool I
don't know anything about these cuz they
happen as they happen there's no
scripted stream of consciousness its
thoughts stringing together with other
thoughts like a DNA strand you're not
feeling when you close your eyes and it
feels so good oh sleep that's called
sleep sleep uh-huh our world is how are
you how do i express myself fashion
oh I haven't mentioned this in a video
mamrie Hart and I are coming to London
and Dublin and we're doing this might
get weird y'all shows there so in the
description of this video there is a
link to buy tickets if you are
interested we'll be there over
Thanksgiving we are foregoing
our us food holiday to come entertain
you guys in the UK so please buy some
ticket come hang out with us have we
written the show horse not will we write
it on the flight out to London
absolutely is it gonna be a fun time up
for interpretation just recording the
audio I'll be funny if it's not no will
be funny just being sad I mix up words
sometimes how's everyone handling the
state of the world oh you're drinking
regularly to repress your feelings to
internet I'm so inclusive thank you I'm
happy to hear that my lifestyle choices
are on trend but what about me isn't on
trend
ow should we look at what
happening in Twitter moments no
definitely not because it's too real I
agree this isn't a new favorite way to
hang out people hang out the Rolly
chairs all the time
look how engaging this is are you
engaged by this have you subscribed yet
oh no one else on the Internet's doing
this in all honesty though yes the world
is shucked but I would love to give a
round of applause to all the people that
are out marching in their respective
cities voicing their values I think
that's really really commendable and
doing it peacefully I know some stuff
got out of hand in some different areas
but the ability to peacefully protest
and make your voice heard in a way
that's nonviolent is to me really
incredible and so I commend any of you
that have been doing that over the last
few days I treated this video that said
it was in downtown LA and it turns out
it was a protest in Venezuela and
everyone got duped by it but then I
found a video of thousands and thousands
of people walking down Wilshire
Boulevard in Los Angeles and I tweeted
it out and I was really awestruck by
that visual it was really incredible the
optimistic positive side of me thinks
that things happen as they're supposed
to I know that that sounds stupid and
maybe very naive but I do feel that now
more than ever have I been able to feel
and notice people that are extremely
positive extremely motivated and
extremely resilient and yes those people
already existed for sure but in times of
true turmoil that's when those people
really take action and that's been
incredibly inspirational to see and so
kudos how are you not loving this one of
the main reasons to buy a home
is so that you can just have a space to
do your activities worth it
how to breath kind of athletes do it
let's look at Twitter moments for a
second let's see what's happening
outside of the obvious nonsense to date
following severe quake in New Zealand
and we're done and we're out and it's
all cancel cancel it join the scammer
this might have been completely out of
focus this entire time and my camera
lens hasn't been focused either I burned
my finger the other day on a Kardashian
beauty product it's like that's the most
American sentence I could ever say out
loud in a video
happy birthday if it's your birthday
today cool for you getting close to that
sweet sweet expiration date if I could
write birthday cards that's what they
would say should I make a line of
birthday cards here's a quick cute gets
like this ring guys like these earrings
cool okay hashtag soon vacation dad is
tired o occasion dad is having what
seems to be an existential crisis
recorded on camera cool make guacamole
today
whenever I'm hungover I like to create
something with my hands just to feel
like I'm not complete peace if a piece
of [ __ ] is of my quality of human is
balanced by my ability to create
[ __ ] is this dancing dancing this
video is a lot of nonsense but right
they oh by the way thank you for liking
and watching the video from last Friday
Ivanka Trump's exclusive message to all
of you if you haven't had encourage you
can check that out I was really really
wonderfully overwhelmed in a positive
way about all of the positive feedback
thank you guys
I mean what it's impossible to be
sincere in this outfit if you guys made
it this far in the video good karma is
gonna come your way also let me know
what kind of videos you guys want to see
in the future I am one of those
youtubers that
not preemptively get ahead of her
schedule could you guess what a surprise
so let me know any types of holiday
videos or winter themed videos or just
general videos that you guys would like
to see because I'm all ears and wide
open those shoes that the cash and Dad
one the rest of you more than one you
win yeah I lose okay that's it for this
video thank you guys for being here I
really appreciate it if you enjoyed this
on any level give it a thumbs up so I
know and hit this button right here and
subscribe to this YouTube channel
because we have fun
I don't know Listerine strips this is
some straight-up for sure right I've two
of them people sign the laboratory and
develop these Listerine strips can we
get them on something like way better
for Humanity we might get them on cancer
early presidential impeachment I don't
know